I want to continue on with my story my
story consists of this we talked about
the gang banging [ __ ]
we talked about my upbringing and all
the above it's a cold thing right
one of your siblings becomes a victim of
circumstances that may have or may have
not been a result of your karma
understand what I'm saying and I said is
just to say right I got buried my sister
the more my sister younger than me you
understand what I'm saying
I got go to her wait today at these
flowers for my mom ain't talked to my
mom in 12 years
you know 12-month [ __ ] years ain't
talked to my mom my sister died two
streets over in a [ __ ] team yeah she
she was a druggie all another [ __ ]
but at the same time right it's like
the people that you
that you may deal with endeavor whatever
the circumstances is you don't want that
[ __ ] for your family you don't want that
[ __ ] for your for your siblings
especially when your siblings is younger
than you
I'd be fifty years old next month fifty
my sister was 37 all right thirty-seven
she lied to me for many many many many
years that she wasn't doing this or
doing that but she was enthused and
excited about that lifestyle that whole
lifestyle to the point where that burger
her death her [ __ ] baby daddy
he got sixteen years he an opinion being
an opinion for three years already and
uh yeah three kids
these kids my nieces and my nephews and
my [ __ ] house right now I got
to raise them I just seen my little
niece two hours ago my wife get it bring
her home bring her home bring her home
we gotta wait today 3:30 you understand
what I'm saying
my mom [ __ ] nice she's 16 years old
yo you smoking weed smoke your [ __ ]
crystal doing all this other little
[ __ ] but her little punk-ass friends
and I grabbed her come on let's go home
come on she pulled away from me I see it
hurt you know I see it hurt
I ain't talked to my mom in 12 years I
talked to my mom on the phone last night
for two hours for two more [ __ ] hours
man you know
I did a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] in my life
a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] I understand
this whole concept but is karma [ __ ] and
you reap what you sow that's life
that's the way it is go but it's like
when she hate home you know
I see hurt man you know it hurt deep
I says was thirty seventy years old she
died
we waiting on the autopsy now we don't
know if it was natural cause did a
[ __ ] killer
you see OD you know justice all that
[ __ ] you know it was real [ __ ] though
man you know I did a lot of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] man in my day you know I [ __ ] up
[ __ ] bro a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] man and
I don't wish this life on nobody it's my
baby sister right here man it's my baby
sister it's her weight her weight is
today she left three kids ain't got a
[ __ ] job I'm out here doing my [ __ ]
[ __ ] up whatever trying to live
trying to survive
trying to take care of my [ __ ] kids
my [ __ ] girl now I got three more
mouths to feed you know as a result of
this lifestyle
I always just [ __ ] on my worst enemy
this [ __ ] right here man
you're feeling through here home
you know fill it till you go home I
ain't being home the photos I've been up
for three days three days I've been up I
ain't no sleeping three [ __ ] days
because I'm tired of dealing with the
crying and it's too much for me I'm not
I can't say I any emotional person but
it's a [ __ ] up [ __ ] you know
a farmer loses dead in the team father
Dan in team
I'm 13 years older than her it's my baby
system man
[Music]
and reduce things differently
I would and a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] in
my life man I [ __ ] up [ __ ]
see at heart
you'll never feel it unless he hit you -
that's a home that I said
[Music]
I'll be 50 years old next month
pretty and after I will be able to see
their three grandkids
I don't know what I don't know what the
newer purpose is for me today and a lot
of [ __ ] up [ __ ] I'm a prison
I did some things
coming up same type of pain and I'm
feeling right now
I may have afflicted that on somebody
else that [ __ ] ain't cool man when you
gotta feel that same [ __ ] you know her
boyfriend he suspect I wanna kill it
[ __ ] you know
just make a left my sister in a tent be
panning in called [ __ ] emblems man
you know
you tell me when he left my sister right
she was live okay my sister only came
down here [ __ ] with you
I ain't trying to do life in prison
you reap what you sow man when you do
[ __ ] then that should come back to you
too [ __ ] up filling it ain't cold man
you know thang khuu
[Music]
I did a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] growing up
now
I understand and I know how your people
fell
you know I don't people fail
I don't know it is what God wanted me to
see then well he wanted me to feel I
ain't been sleeping three days man three
days crying hey I look at my nieces and
nephews hey daddy in jail they mama dead
ain't got nobody else I ain't got my own
[ __ ] together
got a [ __ ] a feed three more mouths
yeah I'm a real man uh this his whole
lifestyle when it come to this gang
banging [ __ ] this selling drugs [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] man that [ __ ] ain't good
then cool ain't for nobody
cuz in the end you either gonna die
you're gonna be in prison for the rest
of your life
[ __ ] can't get you you don't get
the deck stain close to you
[ __ ] ain't no game out here man it ain't
no game [ __ ] this real-life [ __ ] is real
life [ __ ] that happens every [ __ ] day
every day I have a baby my baby sister
I've been my baby sister does that mean
years old three kids
I'm a little more [ __ ] nice she's
running around here with her little
[ __ ] friends and getting high smoking
[ __ ] Cristal and all this other
[ __ ]
my momma telling me get her man your
home get her bring her home she snatched
away from me man she pulled away from me
like she's 17 years old the [ __ ] I
supposed to do
need the same [ __ ] I sell drugs
too
you see any fair
my best advice man to anybody out here
and his lifestyle is glamour
whatever the [ __ ] you choose to call his
[ __ ] it ain't good today [ __ ] hit home
when they see at home
I should take a chunk up out of you and
then knock you down and you're [ __ ]
right tough you in how tough you mate
thank you is cuz anybody can get it no
matter who you is where you frog you can
get it for real not for play I'll play
now I don't know what the [ __ ] to do I'm
in I'm at the crossroads where what I'm
supposed to do do I get upset get grimy
do what I know best do I have some
[ __ ] common sense common sense basic
common sense not to do the things that
ain't right
no matter who it is what's right is
what's right what's wrong is what's
wrong
if you feel it in your heart and in your
soul and you doing something that you
know anyway you don't supposed to be
doing it
bottom line now if you want some other
[ __ ] and you want to be tough guy
whatever you know I mean and you pushing
any you doing what they do you with the
business we know what it do understand
that
you could be subject to the same
[ __ ] pain that you inflict on
somebody else
when I see a home in Philly Philly
har-har
Janu is life this
yesterday nothing easy come easy go
50 years old next month did way too much
[ __ ] 20-some years in prison
off and on first time I went to prison I
was 19 I [ __ ] I knew [ __ ] with
homeboys enemies whatever dang here
today
no God allowed me to see three
grandbabies I got three grandkids three
two girls and a boy
God seen me through that and I know
without his grace and everything else
that come with it I want to be sitting
in front of you talk to you today man no
I buried my little sister man
I don't understand I don't understand
now
baby sister change their [ __ ] diapers
change their [ __ ] kids diapers